France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe nous sommes ensemble
sur France 24 et Radio France
Internationale nous prenons cette
semaine la direction de la péninsule
iberic car l'Espagne est sous le feu des
projecteurs à divertitres en réaction à
des élections régionales décevantes le
Premier ministre socialiste a annoncé un
scrutin anticipé pour le 23 juillet
prochain or l'Espagne prend au 1er
juillet la présidente tournante de
l'Union européenne et ce pour 6 mois
alors y a-t-il conflit de calendrier on
va en parler tout de suite avec Rose
Emmanuel Alvarez bonjour vous êtes le
ministre des Affaires étrangères de
l'Espagne chargé aussi des affaires
européennes donc de ce dossier bien sûr
vous êtes parfaitement francophone vous
étiez je rappelle ambassadeur à Paris
assez longtemps si vous le voulez bien
on va parler bien sûr de votre pays mais
on va commencer par l'actualité
diplomatique la plus brûlante la plus
choquante aussi l'Ukraine destruction du
barrage de kakovka qui a inondé une zone
de plus de
600 km², 5900 personnes à évacuer le
président
gedinski a parlé d'écocide
ukrainien et russe se rejettent la
responsabilité quelle est votre
conviction très clairement nous ce qui
s'est passé la destruction des
infrastructures subiles et complément
contraire au droit international
humanitaire je rappelle que même les
guerres même les guerres ont des lois on
est face en désastreumanitaires qui va
avoir un impact immense sur la vie des
milliers des milliers de personnes et en
même temps un désastre environnemental
par conséquent ce qui nous voulons c'est
qu'ils n'ont quête et que ceux qui sont
coupables de ces crimes comme tous les
crimes qui sont en train d'être commis
sur l'Ukraine depuis le début de
l'agression illégale injuste broutale de
la Russie envers l'Ukraine répand devant
la justice internationale et l'Espagne
est engagé auprès procureur Ken de la
cour pén ale internationale pour faire
toute la lumière sur ces crimes et qu'il
est pas d'unité alors le président
ukrainien vous le dit merci a déploré
l'absence d'aide humanitaire dans le sud
du pays est-ce que l'Union européenne a
été suffisamment réactive et soutenante
on doit faire toutes ces campés pour
l'Ukraine la possession de l'Espagne est
très claire on sera à côté à côté des
loukrens tant qu'il les faudra et en ce
moment cette semaine même on a commencé
très très vite dès qu'il y en a eu les
premières nouvelles des astres monétaire
écologique qui vient de ces produits
pour cette attaque contrat les barrages
pour renforcer les paquets humanitaires
qui ont donné
latérale pour l'Espagne il s'agit du
plus grand paquet d'aide humanitaires
que n'a jamais donné dans notre histoire
à un seul pays et bien sûr notre voix va
s'élever dans à Bruxelles dans l'Union
européenne pour que l'Union fasse de
même est-ce que vous êtes aussi ministre
espagnol en charge du développement je
rappelle effectivement un paquet de
combien à peu près jusque là on a
contribué à hauteur des cinq millions
d'euros au niveau d'aide humanitaires de
250 millions d'euros de la dernière conf
échange des réconstructions et on va
faire un nouveau un effort à la
conférence à Londres pour la
reconstruction des l'Ukraine elle
souhaite l'Ukraine que l'Espagne lui
fournisse un système de défense de
missiles à anti-aériens patriotes vous
disposez de deux batteries patriotes en
service une sur le territoire turc une
pour défendre votre propre territoire
est-ce que vous pouvez accéder à cette
demande nous jusqu'ici on a toujours
répondu des mondes de l'Ukraine chaque
fois qui on pouvait ce sont les choses
en accord avec tous nos partenaires
européens en voyant qui peut faire qui
ou quoi mieux et en même temps en étant
sûr que c'est le plus efficace pour que
l'Ukraine et ça c'est vraiment notre but
plus d'effondre à ça souveraineté
ça son intégrité territoriale et qui
puisse défendre les civils innocents on
a déjà fourni poussière système de
défense a intérêt réel et évidemment on
va étudier toute demande qui vient vient
de l'Ukraine avec cette deux volets
alors parlons maintenant de la situation
de votre pays suite aux élections du 28
mai sur 10 grandes villes vous n'en
contrôler plus qu'une à peine et à peine
quatre régions sur 10 avec un score de
31% le Parti populaire vous a devancé
vous êtes à 28%, qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé les Espagnols
et les précédents a pris note de ces là
et dans un acte une décision qui est
complètement démocratique très très
vraiment pratique il a souhaité ont
clarification donc clarification sur les
gouvernements espagnols donc
clarification pour avoir on voit forte
pendant la présidence et l'Union
européenne de la part de l'Espagne qu'il
avait qui va l'avoir à partir du permis
juger et par conséquence il a appelé les
Espagnols à voter cette fois au niveau
national les premières jours qui étaient
possibles les 23 juillet et sur les
résultats plus cher chose les parties
populaires là où il a gagné il nous a
dévoncé avait très peu au Parti
socialiste la plupart des gouvernements
que les
dans les pays mais aussi peut-être l'an
prochain pour les élections européennes
au Parlement européen ce qui dirait Marc
c'est que les valeurs de l'Europe les
valeurs qui ne sont seulement des belles
idées philosophiques bictions les
moteurs des années où les progrès et la
paix ont été vraiment pression en Europe
sans défis à l'extérieur de l'Europe par
l'agression russe en Ukraine mais aussi
à l'intérieur de nos sociétés ces
valeurs sont la diversité la pluralité
l'état des droits croire au pluralisme
et si mais peut-être que les Européens
n'y adèrent plus à ces valeurs c'est la
question aussi ce qu'il faut pas que la
sociale démocratie se remette l'Union
européenne
parce que c'est les moteurs de la
croissance c'est le moteur de
l'instabilité c'est les moteurs de la
paix élémentaire de nos démocraties et
de nos systèmes économiques et je pense
qu'il faut faire face il faut parler
très très entièrement et certains mots
les partis politiques que j'ai
représentants et que les présidents
Sanchez et la tête on s'est présente le
23 juillet avec un programme très clair
arrêtez cette vague en Espagne vous êtes
très proche de Pedro Sanchez monsieur
mini je le précise
justement ces élections fixées au moment
le 23 juillet ou c'est le tout début de
la présidente tournante de l'Espagne
pour 6 mois est-ce qu'elle ne risque pas
de résulter d'un certain immobilisme
pour cette présidence on saura pas qui
sera le prochain ministre on n'aura pas
bien préparé les dossiers si surtout si
ça change si le gouvernement changer
radicalement absolument pas absolument
pas tes précautions
il a eu de tous les couleurs et de tous
les manières la France sa présidence qui
était un grand succès il a il a eu une
élection présidentielle à des tours une
élection législative en changement de
gouvernement et ça a été un succès il a
eu des présidents avec un gouvernement
en fonction les six mois des changements
des gouvernements militaires absolument
pas et cela fait un an et demi que les
prépare je suis président du comité
organitaire de la présidence les thèmes
sont choisis les villes on était choisis
les dates non ça sera vraiment un grand
succès pour l'Europe d'ailleurs sont
attendus des textes très importants qui
doivent être poussés par cette
présidence la révision du marché de
l'électricité
en profondeur le plan de 500 millions
d'euros pour les productions de
munitions en Europe à destination de
l'Europe et de l'Ukraine l'impact de
stabilité et de croissance révisée
est-ce que justement vous aurez
l'occasion de faire passer tous ces
textes et ce que vous avez l'espoir de
le faire
un gouvernement complètement
pro-européen et une société parmi les
plus européenne en Europe en tout cas on
va tous me mettre à l'émir de nous-mêmes
pour les faire on a besoin de 26 autres
et de Parlement européen en tout cas
toute l'énergie toute la volonté
politique de l'Espagne avant d'être pour
réussir quels sont vos vrais priorités
si vous devez les définir rapidement les
présidents formel mais il a des grands
thèmes qui se voient déjà
parce qu'il devait le faire devant la
plénière du Parlement européen ça a été
reporté en septembre
tout ce qui touche à la guerre faire
revenir la paix en Europe et faire face
aux conséquences économiques et sociales
de cette agression brutale de la de la
Russie à l'Ukraine ça veut dire
compléter la réforme du marché
électrique européen rien de très déçu
Europe faire l'Europe à nouveau et ne
sont interprises compétitif protéger les
citoyens face à ses conséquences
économiques et sociales qui nous jeûne
puisse avoir accès au logement l'égalité
en femme les gens en situation
d'handicap et regarder vers l'extérieur
l'Europe avait soin d'amis Dalier dans
le monde les 17 et les 18 juillet il va
voir depuis beaucoup d'années on tenait
pas un sommet Europe Amérique latine
Union européenne l'Amérique latine c'est
vrai est un grand producteur de de
cuivre de lithium mais d'importantes
quantité de pétales gaz naturel
et vous êtes évidemment très proche en
raison de la langue de cette Amérique
latine le projet de la Commission
européenne d'un grand pacte merc avec le
Mercosur Argentine Brésil Paraguay
Uruguay est au point mort les
écologistes l'accusent d'être trop
polluants à la France même traîne des
pieds vous allez en faire une priorité
ça c'est rare en priorité des lagena de
l'Europe en Amérique latine vous savez
nous sommes proches pour la langue mais
surtout nous sommes proches tous les sur
européens pour les valeurs parce que
l'Amérique latine comme nous et c'est
très important en ce moment il croit au
multilatéralisme il refuse la guerre
comme une façon de régler des conflits
entre États il adhère nos valeurs et
les mérites n'est pas très clair sur le
dossier ukrainien par exemple
ils sont tous à pratiquer les
résolutions des Nations Unies ont
condamnant cette agression brutale si on
fait partie de ces 144 pays qui ont voté
à l'Assemblée Générale des Nations oui
ce qui est on doit comprendre en Europe
c'est que les accords commerciales vu
avec les cieux parfois il semble
seulement désaccord commercial mais pour
l'Amérique latine c'est aussi un signe
d'engagement politique à long terme avec
l'Amérique latine et si nous ne voulons
pas voir l'Amérique latine s'est tournée
vers d'autres partenaires qui sont
présents nous devons les offrir un
engagement politique fort donc d'accord
avec mercredi vous avez mentionné
finalement le dossier énergétique un les
citoyens européens qui voient les prix
flambés vous poussiez avec Paris pour
que le calcul du prix de l'électricité
soit découpler donc séparés de celui du
gaz vous n'avez pas obtenu gain de cause
en revanche vous avez obtenu que les
installations de renouvelables pour vous
et de centrales nucléaire pour Paris
bien soit prise en compte mieux prise en
compte et puissent faire partie des
investissements et contrats à long terme
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait de ce
compromis ou pas tout à fait parce que
finalement
renouvelable et nucléaire c'est pas
pareil je pense que nous sommes tous
d'accord sur une chose l'Europe n'était
plus se trouver dans la situation où
elle s'est trouvée les 24 février de
l'année dernière c'est-à-dire sur les
chantages énergétiques dans les cas
d'espèces les chantages du gaz de
Vladimir Poutine ça veut dire il faut
compléter les marchés il faut réformer
les marchés des l'énergie un Europe et
ça veut dire compléter les
interconnexions pousser pour les
renouvelables parce que les parties de
renouvelable sera en partie des
souveraineté énergétiques qui nous
savons et maintenir des mécanismes comme
les plafondants de prix du gaz le temps
qu'il les faudra chaque pays a besoin et
à une structure mixte énergétique comme
on dit différents ça je pense que nous
sommes tous d'accord là-dessus mais
l'Espagne est en proie à une sécheresse
historique mais les producteurs de
fraises espagnoles sont dans le viseur
des politiques l'Union européenne qui
veut fixer des amendes des ONG et les
supermarchés militent contre
l'utilisation illégale de de l'eau en
Andalousie et notamment dans la province
de Huelva comment vous allez régler la
guerre de la fraise
les gouvernements étaient très très
clair là-dessus y compris les précédents
du gouvernement première personne il est
contrairement à cette surexploitation
des lots dont cette région pour la
fraise et cette stigmate qui puisse
porter les producteurs dans cette
province espagnole et la responsabilité
du gouvernement régional du Parti
populaire qui nie cette situation qui
nie surtout cette émergence climatique
qui assole l'Espagne mais l'Europe
entier le monde entier on a parlé de la
montée de l'extrême droite sur les
thèmes migratoires en vérité cette
question migratoire elle est toujours
très présente en Europe entre les pays y
compris entre la France et l'Espagne par
exemple la police espagnole a ouvert une
enquête interne sur un haut gradé d'une
ville frontalière à la France qui avait
fixé des jours de repos pour ces troupes
en fonction du nombre de migrants arrêté
finalement la France a renforcé les
contrôles à cette frontière une douzaine
de personnes ont péri quand même en deux
ans à entière quelle politique
migratoire de l'Espagne et avec la
France écoutez sur le cas où vous dites
comme vous dites il est en enquête par
conséquence l'enquête décidera qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé comment il faut agir en
conséquence mais sur la politique
opératoire des l'Espagne et la France ou
nous sommes très proches tous les deux
nous parlons très souvent il y a eu une
chute décentrées réguliers en Espagne
avec 80% cette année par rapport à
l'année dernière c'est la seule route
d'entrée en Europe où il est en descente
surtout de ces niveaux grâce à la
coopération avec les pays d'origine et
des principes et deuxièmement nous nous
croyons très fermement que l'espace
Schengen est un acquis et européenne
vraiment à l'auteur des la monnaie
unique qu'il faut préserver que c'est un
vrai atout pour nos citoyens et par
conséquence tout entrave à la livre
circulation à l'intérieur de Schengen
nous nous la refusons
alors pour terminer juste un petit mot
peut-être on descend plus en Afrique
l'Espagne est une ancienne puissance
coloniale au Sahara occidental et son
retrait en 75 à entraîner un différent
territorial à la suite duquel le Maroc
c'est emparé du territoire l'Algérie
soutient l'autodétermination de ce Sarah
occidental vous êtes rapproché du Maroc
après des tensions justement migratoires
et l'Algérie elle a imposé des sanctions
à votre pays l'Espagne à la suite de ce
changement de position une baisse de 80%
des exportations espagnoles vers l'art
Jerry comment vous allez sortir de ce
piège écoutez la main de l'Espagne a
étendue vers l'Algérie depuis les
premiers jours Espagne est un pays
souverain et princesses
que nous voulons avec l'Algérie c'est
exactement la même chose que nous
voulons avec tous nos voisins exactement
la même chose que nous voulons avec tous
les pays arabes
que l'amitié soit au centre de nos
relations et qu'il soit passé sur les
respects mutuel et les bénéfices mutuels
merci rosé manuel Albaret d'avoir été en
notre compagnie ministre des Affaires
étrangères d'Espagne nous partons
maintenant en direction du Parlement
européen de Bruxelles pour parler de la
pose environnementale que certains
voudraient voir prendre à l'Union
européenne enfin tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord et on le voit dans ce débat qui
vient tout de suite avec ma camarade ma
conso Marie bremo de publicité
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre ici au Parlement
européen à Bruxelles la lutte contre le
changement climatique est-elle encore
une priorité européenne on peut
s'interroger à entendre le président
français Emmanuel Macron le 11 mai
dernier a réclamé une pause
réglementaire des normes
environnementales au nom de la
compétitivité et il a été suivi par le
Premier ministre belge Alexander de Crau
qui lui peut aller plus loin en
renégociant les modalités du pacte vert
qui fixe le cap de la neutralité carbone
du continent et bien en 2050
de la Commission européenne à travers la
voie de son vice-président Frantz
Timmermans on n'a pas le luxe de pose ni
dans la politique climatique ni dans la
protection de notre biodiversité le
néerlandais fait allusion à la bataille
législative qui fait rage autour de la
loi sur la restauration de la nature
censée protéger cette biodiversité le
grand parti de droite le Parti populaire
européen si oppose invoquant de
nouvelles règles trop contraignantes
pour nos agriculteurs certains réclame
même un moratoire sur l'interdiction des
pesticides assiste-t-on finalement à une
offensive contre le leadership
environnemental mondial de l'Union
européenne pour en débattre 2 euros
députés qui illustrent bien ce clivage
une écologiste française Caroline en
hausse bonjour et puis face à vous un
belge du principal partie dans cette
hémicycle le PPE bienvenue Benoît hudget
quelle mouche a piqué d'abord Emmanuel
Macron puis votre premier ministre
Alexander de Crau pour réclamer une
pause environnementale je ne connais pas
les mouches qui tournent autour du
président Macron je ne sais pas quelle
mouche l'appliquer
je vais c'est un exercice difficile pour
moi de devoir défendre Emmanuel Macron
parce que je suis pas d'accord avec
beaucoup de choses mais là en
l'occurrence par rapport à son
intervention elle était fixée sur
l'ensemble des nouvelles règles qui vont
arriver au niveau de la Commission de
nouveaux règlements qui concerne
notamment la protection de la nature pas
sur l'objectif climatique je pense qu'on
doit être correct avec avec chacune et
chacun même si on n'est pas d'accord
avec quelqu'un ça ne peut pas quelque
part tromper ou tronquer les propos
qu'il a pu tenir donc on parle bien
effectivement notamment du Règlement sur
la restauration de la nature ou le
Règlement sur les sur les pesticides oui
je pense que il y a besoin il y a un
besoin effectivement de regarder
l'ensemble de ces de ces nouveautés sous
différentes aspects l'aspect bien sûr
environnemental climatique mais aussi
économique et social c'est ça la
durabilité et de voir les effets pervers
le cas échéant en se compris pour la
biodiversité je vais m'expliquer en 15
secondes c'est pas qu'un enjeu pour les
agriculteurs on aura besoin des
agriculteurs pour pouvoir réussir
effectivement la restauration de la
nature le faire sans eux ce serait
évidemment une erreur fondamental mais
plus largement notre sécurité
alimentaire au niveau européen et un peu
plus que la nôtre puisque aussi on
soutient toute une série de pays par nos
exportations pour les soutenir par
rapport à leur alimentation c'est aussi
un enjeu qui est un enjeu aussi
important si demain on se retrouve dans
un déficit de production au niveau
européen avec une sécurité alimentaire
qui ne serait plus assurée on va
continuer à se nourrir un citoyen
européen il mange trois fois par jour je
vous le dis il continuerai à manger 2 à
3 fois par jour demain et si c'est pour
importer demain davantage de
marchandises davantage de produits
alimentaires avec un impact pour la
biodiversité extrêmement dégradant dans
les pays comme le Brésil Argentine la
biodiversité n'aura strictement rien
gagné et notre dépendance sera plus
grande vous entendez Madame Rose
finalement on oppose toujours économie
et là en l'occurrence sécurité
alimentaire avec écologie alors que les
effets du changement climatique avec en
Espagne en Italie des mois de sécheresse
sans précédent pour ne citer qu'un
exemple parmi d'autres comment vous
expliquer ces prises de position de
leader français et belges alors pour moi
une prise de position elles sont
totalement irresponsables
demandez une pause environnementale pour
moi c'est totalement irresponsable
est-ce que le réchauffement climatique
s'arrête est-ce que la crise sur la
biodiversité s'arrête absolument pas
donc je ne comprends pas comment on peut
aujourd'hui demander une pause
environnementale quand on voit tout ce
qui se passe au niveau du climat alors
le climat va avec la crise de la
biodiversité quand on voit les incendies
que nous avons actuellement quand on
voit les inondations que nous avons
actuellement quand on voit puisque moi
je suis en commission pêche
la population de poissons qui disparaît
en Méditerranée quand on voit
un petit peu
cet effondrement des fonds marins je ne
comprends absolument pas la position de
Monsieur Macron ni du gouvernement belge
enfin de Monsieur de cross je comprends
absolument pas qu'on puisse pour moi
c'est un total danger et
alors le terme de sécurité alimentaire
donc je revenais à dire donc on peut pas
faire une pause environnementale en
sachant tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment alors on a beaucoup parlé de la
souveraineté alimentaire ensuite on
parle de sécurité alimentaire je pense
qu'il faut revoir à la base les
problèmes à la base sur notre mode de
consommation comment on consomme
consommer moins et on va toujours sur le
plus gros empêche on va toujours sur
pêcher plus encore plus encore plus avec
des techniques de pêche qui sont
totalement destructrices pour
l'environnement et c'est pareil en
agriculture je pense que ces modes de
consommation si technique sont à revoir
et les règles environnementales
aujourd'hui on en a besoin sur la loi
sur la restauration de la nature moi
j'ai été rapporté ça empêche par rapport
à la loi sur la restauration de la
nature
que ce soit le PPE la droite ou les
macronistes ont voté un amendement de
rejet sur le texte total de la
commission alors qu'on demandait des
objectifs de restauration avec des dates
de restauration aujourd'hui on a rien on
rejette le texte totalement
de sécheresse en Europe qui peut dire
qu'il y a pas de problème d'inondation
en Europe est-ce que pour autant nous
devons demain alors que nous avons
l'agriculture madame la plus durable au
monde il serait bien de le dire de temps
en temps de défendre leurs agriculteurs
pour dire que ce que nous avons mis en
place au niveau européen fait en sorte
que l'agriculture française est au top
le Belge également et globalement on est
bien meilleur en matière de durabilité
de protection de l'environnement que le
reste du monde donc moi ça améliorer
c'est ça bien sûr que si on doit
continuer à s'améliorer mais on doit
continuer à s'améliorer sans avoir
d'effet de en tant que tel et de faire
en sorte que demain nous importions
davantage notre nourriture ça c'est pas
mon modèle parce que personne n'y
gagnera ni la nature ni la biodiversité
je suppose que vous défendez la
biodiversité avec la même force au
Brésil en Argentine ou ailleurs que chez
nous en Europe c'est ça la différence
pour moi et je pense qu'on doit pas moi
je suis pas pour une pause
environnementale j'étais mise en
environnement j'ai mis en place un coin
de faire rester le plus durable avec les
verres et tout le monde c'est pas ça la
question c'est de se dire revoyons
l'ensemble de ce texte pour faire en
sorte aussi qu'il soit davantage prenant
et
agriculteurs forestiers et autres qui
sont exclus aujourd'hui
de notre mandat
on a voté l'état d'urgence climatique
aujourd'hui on est en train de
travailler sur des textes sur la loi sur
la restauration de la nature
contre l'utilisation des pesticides et
en fait on rejette tout donc finalement
on avance même pas sur une transition je
vais vous prendre un exemple vécu et que
vous connaissez parfaitement que ce soit
dans mon pays ou en Allemagne on a dit
stop plus clair en 2003 dans mon pays on
a dit on en veut plus dans 20 ans on a
rien mis en oeuvre pour y arriver ou
quasiment rien on se retrouve 20 ans
plus tard à prolonger le nucléaire avec
nos vieilles casseroles pour essayer de
s'en sortir malgré tout qu'est-ce qu'on
a conséquence de cela qu'elle a été elle
était la conséquence était tout
simplement d'une part une dépendance
plus importante sur le plan énergétique
et deuxièmement on a produit
l'électricité à base de centrales à
charbon
le climat il a perdu on a on y a perdu
en indépendance énergétique et le climat
attention avec des lois qui sont des
lois finalement perverse ça sent très
beau sur les objectifs on ne peut que
edgarer avec les objectifs mais la
conséquence en ce compris pour le climat
et la biodiversité peut être dans la loi
environnementale
de ce que j'entends vous dites on peut
pas faire ci on peut pas faire ça mais
votre groupe ne veut même pas de
transition on va même pas vers une
transition aujourd'hui je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce qu'il y a d'une
transition exception de transition et
que les objectifs en matière de
biodiversité ils soient concertés
les pesticides est-ce que c'est un bon
message pour le pour les prochaines
élections pour les jeunes et cetera de
vous dire qu'on doit pas réduire les
pesticides non mais les interdire là il
s'agit de il s'agit d'une
interdictionnelle etc on doit le faire
et on le fait déjà et ça diminue mais
j'ajoute alors qu'un autre frontières au
niveau européen que ce soit par rapport
aux pesticides que ce soit par rapport
au respect de la nature que ce soit par
rapport à toutes les conditions
existantes déjà environnementales très
strict qui existe au niveau européen par
rapport à l'agriculture que ces
normes-là elles soient aussi à nos
frontières par rapport à ce qui rentre
sur notre territoire sinon on aura tout
perdu
alors Monsieur part d'agriculture moi je
vais porter parler du volley pêche
empêche on a eu le on se retrouve avec
un certain nombre de choses qui sont
faits au niveau de la commission pêche
sur la loi sur la restauration de la
nature en commission pêche avant les
négociations j'avais demandé au PPE au
libéraux
à savoir si on allait faire des
compromis si on a les pouvoirs entamer
des discussions on m'a dit oui il y a
pas de problème on va pouvoir entamer
les discussions compromis par compromis
on travaille les négociations pour
inclure les propositions du PPE des
libéraux et du groupe rognoux et
finalement au bout on rejette tout donc
en fait ils ont claqué la porte ils ont
absolument claqué un changement de ton
notamment dans les discussions qu'on
peut observer peut-être depuis quelques
mois est-ce que Caroline rose c'est pas
l'Allemagne finalement qui a sifflé un
peu le début de la récré du moins 10 ans
écologique en revenant brutalement sur
l'interdiction des moteurs thermiques
pour 2035 pourtant déjà voté est-ce que
ça parle un peu libéré une certaine
parole oui ça c'est une problématique de
revenir sur une décision qui déjà été
prise c'est un peu l'ouverture à quelque
chose de problématique et oui c'est ça
et oui en effet ça c'est ça a été une
décision de l'Allemagne qui pour moi n'a
pas été correcte puisqu'il y a eu une
négociation il y a des accords qui ont
été pris revenir sur une décision en
fait et du coup se permettre de le faire
par la suite on va perdre de la
crédibilité et pour moi ça c'est juste
c'est un non respect au niveau européen
vous n'avez pas l'air d'accord je suis
pas d'accord parce que à titre personnel
moi j'ai déposé un amendement sur les
véhicules électriques pour dire que ok
non non pour cent qu'on les 10% pour
d'autres possibilités que des véhicules
électriques à partir de 2035 pourquoi
laisser 10% notamment pour qu'on garde
en Europe une force d'innovation et de
recherche dans le reste de type de
carburant qui pourrait exister qui
existe déjà qui peuvent se développer
demain et apporter une solution au
niveau du climat carburant donc de pas
tomber dans le noble garder le niveau
sur la recherche en Europe pour ne pas
que nos chercheurs par ailleurs je pense
que c'est quand même pas si mal deuxième
élément deuxième élément à nouveau on
fixe un objectif
très dogmatique d'accord à échange de
2035 sans que nous soyons préparés
qu'est-ce que ça crée à court terme en
tout cas une dépendance plus forte à la
Chine c'est pas mon modèle la Chine en
terme de démocratie et sur le plan
environnemental un désastre notamment au
Congo ou en Amérique du sud ou encore en
Nouvelle-Zélande donc est-ce que c'est
ça le modèle c'est ça devient très
difficile je vais vous dire une chose
dès qu'on a une nuance ou qu'on veut
voir sa globalement par rapport à
l'ensemble des impacts et en se compris
croyez le bien sur le plan climatique
sur le plan de la biodiversité si on
apporte une nuance par rapport à cela on
est immédiatement traité de
climatosceptique ou ça va on ne l'est
absolument pas je pense que c'est
vraiment important de ne pas prendre de
décision qui finalement vont avoir comme
conséquence un effet contraire à
l'objectif fixé en ce compris pour le
climat bien sûr au niveau social aussi
si je prends l'exemple au niveau social
des véhicules c'est 500 000 emplois en
moins en Europe c'est même si on ajoute
à 200 000 emplois
une offensive puissante des lobbies
industriels et des énergies fossiles si
on regarde d'ailleurs la COP
ensuite vous allez pas être très
contente j'imagine en tant qu'Ecolo à la
fin de l'année à Dubaï avec pour PDG une
compagnie pétrolière nationale et mirati
tout à fait sauf que j'ai c'est quelque
chose que j'ai dénoncé au sein de la
commission Développement comment c'est
possible que le négociateur pour la COP
28 soit une personne qui est en place
qui est PDG d'une industrie fossile moi
ça me pose quand même un problème de
conflit d'intérêt et puis vous parliez
tout à l'heure de l'agriculture et de
l'économie de de pas dissocier
protection de l'environnement et
économie bien sûr qu'il y a des
questions économiques qui se posent mais
aujourd'hui en termes d'agriculture bio
c'est là où on embauche le plus c'est là
où ils ont les meilleurs profits moi je
prends l'exemple de la pêche aussi sur
la pêche artisanale régulièrement je
sors avec des pêcheurs il y a pas très
longtemps je sors avec des pêcheurs qui
pêche 30 kilos par jour qui valorise
leurs produits qui gagnent bien leur vie
avec des techniques de pêche qui n'est
pas
je crois qu'à un moment donné le fait de
pas avoir voté cette loi qui est une loi
très importante sur la restauration de
la nature finalement on va continuer sur
le même système à détruire la planète
Benoît luggen est-ce que finalement
l'Union européenne le problème c'est
qu'elle ne veut plus porter seule les
ambitions environnementales au niveau
mondial et que donc finalement elle
s'aligne un peu sur ce que peut faire la
Chine et les États-Unis pour rester dans
cette compétitivité
non je suis absolument pas d'accord avec
ça je pense que on doit effectivement
regarder ça globalement pour ne pas que
pour protéger effectivement le
territoire européen d'une part et pour
ne pas qu'ils des effets pervers donc
oui il y a toute une série de décisions
qui vont se régler aussi à
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce pour
faire en sorte que oui par rapport au
transport et par rapport aux productions
les normes ce qu'on exige de nos
agriculteurs ou nos pécheurs ce sont les
mêmes normes qui soient exigées par
rapport à ce qui est important aux
autres pays notamment la taxe carbone
mais il y a pas que la taxe carbone
c'est ce qu'on appelle les clauses
miroirs moi j'ai déposé dans toute une
série de textes l'obligation des choses
miroir et reconnaissons que la France
est plutôt avant-gardiste en la matière
et porte en tout cas au moins cette
volonté d'avoir ces clauses miroirs
parce que
ce qui rentre sur le territoire européen
qu'on est les mêmes dons sanitaires
environnementales de bien-être animal si
je prends un exemple très concret pour
l'illustrer beaucoup de choses beaucoup
de choses oui mais attendez madame
est-ce qu'on veut parce que c'est si on
ne fait pas ça c'est destructeur pour
notre emploi c'est destructeur pour la
planète c'est destructeur pour la
biodiversité est-ce que c'est ça notre
modèle alors certes chez nous on aura
bonne conscience verte d'ailleurs chez
nous regardez ah voilà ce qu'on produit
notre biodiversité elle se porte mieux
mais par contre on aurait été bousillé
la biodiversité ailleurs dans le monde
et on aura effectivement mis autrement
notre emploi et notre force stratégique
c'est ça notre modèle quand même Madame
Rose est-ce que la campagne va se jouer
sur ce duel ce conflit entre écologie
économie est-ce que on va encore être
dans d'autres thématiques moi moi
pertinente peut-être moi je pense que
l'écologie doit être au coeur du projet
de société aujourd'hui on voit que les
citoyens et les citoyens ils sont
aujourd'hui ils voient l'importance de
sauver la planète puisqu'on n'a pas un
plan B forcément
allez toujours plus toujours plus sur le
produit sur le capitalisme sur le
productivisme je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut relocaliser revoir avec
nos paysans revoir avec nos pécheurs
artisans je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
jeunesse est tout à fait consciente
des effets du dérèglement climatique et
des ravages que peut faire l'industrie
moi je pense que il faut aller sur cet
axe là parce que c'est c'est pour la
survie de notre planète tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas
le taf et puis on a plus le temps
quelques mots de conclusion on a
absolument pas le choix mais on le fait
déjà moi j'invite chacune et chacun à
voir comment notre agriculture vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça à évoluer de
façon extrêmement positive ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a plus de problème ça veut
dire qu'on doit être fait aussi l'Europe
qui se culpabilise tout le temps et qui
se fouettent et qui ne soutient pas
effectivement ces agriculteurs à
fortiori ceux qui font des efforts et se
mépris l'exemple du bio ils se développe
et de façon exponentielle et tant mieux
orme et je pense qu'une pause
merci encore à vous d'avoir été en notre
compagnie et vous restez sur nos
antennes pour la suite des programmes
[Musique]